seconde partie de cette page de l'écho
la chronique de l'écho on va
s'intéresser au handicap
oui tout à fait un le handicap un forum
était organisé à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin c'était ce
jeudi
forum emploi handicap on regarde
ensemble ce reportage faciliter la
recherche d'emploi des personnes
handicapées c'est la démarche de ce
forum qui s'est tenu ce jeudi à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et où une trentaine d'entreprises du
territoire étaient présentes
l'idée de permettre à ces demandeurs
d'emploi de passer plus de temps avec
des recruteurs potentiels pour
multiplier leurs chances dans gauche et
de pouvoir centraliser leurs démarches
nous avons en effet une demande des
entreprises qui porte sur des emplois
qui sont relativement qualifiés et nous
avons des travailleurs handicapés qui
sont en très grand nombre en situation
de
de sous emploi ou de non emploi etc
publica ont un faible niveau de
qualification donc vraiment un problème
d'adéquation entre l'offre et la demande
d'emploi
ce sont des entreprises qui qui ont une
volonté d'embaucher des
dix travailleurs handicapés pour remplir
leur quota de 6%
j'ai déjà fait un forum comme ça à paris
et il ya beaucoup moins de monde sur les
stands travail et handicapés donc autant
en faire beaucoup plus la loi oblige en
effet les entreprises de plus de 20
salariés a recruté six pour cent de son
personnel handicapé un taux peu
respectés en france qui donne lieu à une
amende verser à l'agefiph
mais certains groupes ont pris de
l'avancé comme la poste venu recruter
des facteurs guichetiers conseillers
financiers
la poste aujourd'hui est capable
d'aménager un certain nombre de
dispositifs que ce soit dès l'entrée en
sélection puisque aujourd'hui on est en
capacité d'aménager les tests de
sélection
on est aussi en capacité d'aménager les
dispositifs de formation professionnelle
et bien sûr à terme là on est aussi en
capacité d'aménager deux des postes de
travail
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisera à
nouveau un forum emploi handicap lors de
la semaine de l'emploi en février
prochain
e et nos invités nous ont rejoints en
plateau sylvie lecoq bonsoir vous êtes
responsable du service d'accueil des
étudiants handicapés le s attache en
abrégé l université de versailles saint
quentin à vos côtés pierre de la touche
bonsoir bonsoir à vous vous êtes
président de la ph uef toujours à
l'université c'est l'association
d'accueil des personnes handicapées dans
les universités françaises
alors tout d'abord une réaction sur ce
forum en convient de voir est ce que
vous pensez l'un et l'autre que c'est
une démarche efficace voire nécessaire
parce que ça s'adressait pas forcément
aux étudiants là c'était plus générale
mais pour les personnes handicapées ce
que ça peut débloquer des embauches je
trouve que c'est extrêmement important
donc j'ai cette université cet univers
cette association j'ai la chance de
diriger depuis maintenant un an et demi
et c'est vrai que nous avons des
étudiants qui sont un petit peu gêné de
faire part de leur handicap et je pense
que des personnes qui sont devenus
ensuite
qui font partie du monde du travail sont
sont heureux de voir qu'il y à des
initiatives qui sont mises en place pour
permettre une meilleure insertion dans
le monde du travail et donc une démarche
qui peut se révéler plutôt efficace
alors avec vous dont on va parler de la
scolarisation un des étudiants
handicapés ils étaient environ 150 l'an
passé à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin de handicaps
divers moteurs ou psychique sur dix neuf
mille étudiants
sylvie lecoq quelle est la mission du s
arrache alors la mission du est sage et
d'aménager des aides matérielles et
humaines pour que nos étudiants puissent
mener à bien leur étude est passé dans
des conditions optimales leurs examens
commencent à s'organiser exactement que
l'on sait détecter vous m'expliquez
qu'il ya un travail fait avec le médecin
le la médecine étudiante donc voit les
étudiants propose un aménagement et nous
le s2h on le met en place avec l'aide
deux relais handicap sur place dans les
composantes donc qu'ils sont sur chacun
de nos sites
les composantes ça peut être donc des
iut les yeux ouverts aux institutions
vous disiez à une action humaine et
matérielle mais aussi vous avez un rôle
de formation et de sensibilisation
notamment l'aide humaine peut-être que
vous pouvez nous en parler on voit qu'il
ya bien un engagement d autres étudiants
par exemple l'année dernière 21
étudiants ont été salariés donc des jobs
étudiants en tant que secrétaire
d'examen par exemple c'est important
aussi ce lien entre étudiants handicapés
et étudiants valides
si je la paie seulement parce que
effectivement pour un étudiant lambda ce
faire des études n'est pas forcément
simple et pour un étudiant handicapé il
ya aussi le poids des préjugés qu'on
peut avoir
et finalement nous avons reçu pas mal de
retours de la journée qui a été organisé
l'année dernière la journée handivalides
avec le sav h et les personnes qui
étaient non handicapés étaient très
contents de devoir
comment les étudiants handicapés pouvait
pouvait vivre et les étudiants
handicapés étaient était était heureux
d'avoir de pouvoir montrer tout
simplement que que finalement on peut
avoir qu on peut avoir des préjugés mais
ce sont des personnes avant tout comme
il a fallu une journée pour ça est-ce
que sans cette journée ce serait
possible de créer ce lien entre
étudiants en situation de handicap et
les étudiants valides
ça se fait pas naturellement on essaye
de le créer mais c'est vrai que cette
journée permet vraiment de briser les
tabous et permet vraiment de rapprocher
les étudiants valides et les étudiants
handicapés véritablement pointé du doigt
pour pour que les échanges se fassent
entre les différents étudiants
vous êtes vous-même étudiant en droit
qu'est ce que vous pensez globalement de
l'accueil des étudiants handicapés
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
améliorer quelles sont les difficultés
majeures
le problème principal selon moi c'est
un problème évidemment d'accessibilité
mais aussi je me suis rendu compte et
c'était pas du tout ce que je pense et
lorsque j'ai créé cette association il
ya un problème un petit peu de
psychologique des étudiants qui sont qui
sont perdus les étudiants handicapés des
étudiants handicapés qui sont perdus et
qu'ils ne savent pas forcément
voilà comment faire comment faire pour
pouvoir
voilà pour pouvoir passer des examens
clairement il ya des étudiants qui sont
handicapés qui ne souhaitent pas
forcément en parler
et alors ça leur permet de bénéficier
notamment la suter d'examen dira ok
aussi des de matériel ça peut être des
ordinateurs des dictaphones etc
j'aimerais j'aimerais revenir avec vous
sur ville au coq sur le financement de
toutes ces aides
c'est un budget global de 70000 euros on
le disait pour l'ade matérielles
humaines la formation la sensibilisation
donc vous avez bien évidemment des
subventions du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et puis de l'université bien sûr mais ce
n'est pas suffisant depuis peu vous
faites appel à des entreprises
partenaires
comment est-ce que ça se passe ces
partenariats donc nous essayons donc de
développer des partenariats privilégiés
donc avec des entreprises du privé
donc concrètement nous avons besoin de
budget supplémentaire pour pouvoir aider
au mieux nos étudiants vous fait un
appel aux dons de chaque année
oui oui on donc on fait des mailings ont
fait des contacts par téléphone et ont
sur des forums comme celui ci ou sur
notre prochain forum de début décembre
et en contrepartie a donc en
contrepartie nous nous route ont toutes
leur les offres de stages d'emplois ou
d'alternance qui peuvent proposer pour
nos étudiants en situation de handicap
et idem quand nous étudions recherche un
stage nous les soumettons à ses
entreprises partenaires
merci à tous d'être venus de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
plateau vous avez mentionné ce forum
forum emploi stage de l'université sera
le 4 décembre au le vauban donc sur
l'université à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
juste la fois en plus très brièvement il
très brièvement sachez que le meilleur
vendeur de france travaillent dans les
yvelines il s'appelle badr m race il a
28 ans et a réussi à doubler en deux ans
le chiffre d'affaires de la société de
logiciels informatiques pour laquelle
ils travaillent à vélizy-villacoublay le
titre de meilleur vendeur juniors de
france il a été décerné par les
dirigeants commerciaux de france c'était
l'info en plus donc de cette chronique
de l'écossé la fin du set 8 pour ce 15
novembre c'était le 220e numéro ce soir
je vous retrouve lundi avec de nouveaux
invités n'oubliez pas vendredi l'édition
du week-end présenté par catherine cela
tôt dès 18h à lundi donc excellent
week-end très bonne soirée déjà